thing to remember is the art is
concentric and throughout the centuries
a good way of understanding that is is
the uh so Above So Below So within so
without okay so if I have non-c
contestation
internally you're not supposed to have
externally um no matter how much much I
so for
example um I might use a cultivation
drill where he's pressing and he's
pushing okay with spinal displacement
and then I internalize that and that is
a way of developing that internally I'm
not contesting but externally this is a
contestation you see so hence the art
will move things so same thing
internally I'm doing the same uh yield
so for ex or the same internal non-c
conation so for example if he comes out
and he now pushes on that
angle it's not going anywhere do you see
I don't I
don't I think people make a mistake is
that they take a internal cultivation
field and then violated at the external
level this is not concentric thought
Okay so so just because I move into an
external yield it doesn't mean that I'm
not doing the same exact thing okay I am
doing the same exact thing internally
I'm just now concentrically consistent
throughout my movement okay so you
have you have a uh
internal internalization so internally
I'm not contesting and you can do all of
this
you see on an external
contestation okay so all I'm doing here
is you're you're pushing at me and then
I remain internal and and I can just go
through you you see but that's not the
art okay because I'm just
pushing externally on this line okay so
I have to go around this point
you
see and any point in the turn any point
in the turn so let's say we're here and
he comes
out it's the
same
okay there you
go comes
out it's the
same and any angle so for example
here's this part come out sit
up you
see so as you guys are getting able to
internalize their energy all you're
doing with it now though is trying to be
more powerful you see so and so you're
like oh I'm going to put the quaw into
that and you're very powerful now but
it's not the AR okay so I still use the
qua but I'm going around in you see and
it's extremely soft right okay and so
same thing here you can go here and drop
the chi do you
see but I I as I am not contesting so
same thing see feel that contesting
angle so I go this way you see okay well
and then same thing here you're like
there oh I got you because I can qua the
hell out of you do you see but look all
right you
see so if I can sum up this
point
historically it's an concentric
epistemology what you're doing on the
inside you have to do on the outside
you yes we do train for the inside
isolated from the outside but that's a
cultivation
field hence why when we go more live you
have to do both or you're [\h__\h] do you
get that you can't you can't do those
straight angles and [\h__\h] like that okay
so if you're
trying to uh get the um the spiritual
aspect
okay you could be fine here on the
inside
but when you when you come back and you
go I'm going to qua the [\h__\h] out of you
you lost the spiritual aspect and the
mind does not drop okay which is which
is somewhat different from I was
internalizing your young aspect it's not
it's not quite the same okay remember
it's a kind of
inverse
cultivation
model I cannot have the Mind
drop when I am not internalizing your
young aspect however internalizing the
Yang aspect does not automatically
guarantee that my mind drops okay and
when you when you're using the internal
for just power over the guy your mind
won't drop okay so I use both internal
external
to do the whole thing okay so let's go
back to the Z to the Zen you you start
your Zen with the tissue dropping okay
so the same thing as I do this my
skeletal system is giving me the
feedback that I can feel my tissue
dropping okay you're giving me the
feedback by allowing me to follow that
in
space okay so meaning the way your grip
is telling me don't go here okay my
skeletal system is telling me let the
rest fall in contrast to that so you are
my contrast that's giving me my model to
work
so if you come over
Virginia and you could be at this angle
and you just you can do whatever okay
and know I won't you you can push up
whatever angle okay and it won't
change what I'm
doing it doesn't
matter
okay
[Music]
um so at where you guys are
at when you when you you're going to
feel that cuz they're per prescription
spinally
displacing uh you have to get off of
that
line
okay you have to get off that line no
not here and
then you can get off of it any number of
ways if you watch that video I got off
it any number of ways cuz he he comes in
a little different every time okay
reconcile yes internally you're going to
feel the young aspect that you're
internally reconciling but you go around
that
energy okay you're going to feel it
you're going to feel it go around the
energy
okay and why I had you pushing is to
show that even though it's very soft and
doesn't have the contention model that
makes me feel powerful you can't do
anything to me just like if I stopped at
any point you can't push that arm in do
do you see that so yes it's it is
soft but what it really is is non-c
contesting do you see it's non- if you
push if you push past that you would
feel right everything that you're trying
to do
which is integrity of your organization
I have integrity of my organization but
it never enters into contest with you
okay okay